hello everybody and welcome you all
so today we have a very interesting
session coming up for this react which
is called react router so let's get
started with react router and see what
it offers
so friends the first important thing
about what is the routing
as we know it very well the routing is
synonyms of
navigation any application whether you
talk about multi-page application or
single page application it always
requires a routing
through this routing you will be making
your applications
uh you know to be navigate from one part
to another part like you never call
login page registration page and you've
got a lot of links available
and when you click on those links
application will take you towards those
necessary pages but here in react these
are component centric architecture
so here you will be having a components
loaded
okay
so as we know in a traditional web
development routing plays a very very
crucial role so that you can navigate
through
okay now
react router so what is the react router
so we know this react router is a client
and server side routing library provided
by the rehack it is a javascript
libraries which is normally known for
creating the attractive user interfaces
now here the traditional react router is
available on the web
okay and the server
so
with using traditional node.js
based application which is you know it
is designed for developing a server-side
java based javascript based applications
and on react networks once again for
mobile-based
environment for react applications
now react router components so browser
router so typical we say the browser
router is this is one of the component
because react router comes with lot many
api so here's one of the api which is
called browser router so browser router
is something
from where
okay it uses the traditional html5
history api which is one of the main
component
so
it keeps your
url in sync with what you are navigating
through
okay so next we have a call routes
so routes are basically chosen based on
what best matches you are providing it
so that when you click on those links so
appropriate route will get loaded for
you so-called components
so now we have a call link so the
traditional link components are used to
basically create a hyperlinks like ahrf
how we used in html pages
so
to different
uh from the traditional react ap
application so it is mainly designed
focus on navigation throughout the
applications
and now we have a call switch so
traditionally switch what it does it
renders the first routes and matches the
location rather than rendering all the
matching route like whichever has come
it is like a typical switch case
whichever comes it make it available and
come out
that's how it provides
okay so installation wise you need to
have
first
you have to create the react based
application by using
npx create react app so
create react app is a tool provided by
the
official facebook and the router hyphen
tutorial is the name of the project
okay so you'll be using this command to
create a new project for you and post
that
you have to install
this particular dependency called react
hyphen outer hyphen dom so this
dependency you need to install post
first
uh i would say
the message is executed so once the
first command is ready then you will be
going inside this npm
install and then you say react router
dom so this is how the steps are
and
now we'll talk about demo so let's get
started with the demo part
okay everybody so it's time to
get into some hands-on
so i already have a project ready with
me which we have created with using
create react app so my project name is
react hyphen app
and i would like to create a new uh
router based example here so the
dependency regarding react hyphen router
hyphen dom is already
installed so if you see this
package.json react router dom is already
there in place so we would like to start
now
developing those router based examples
so to make it happen what we will do is
here in my src
we will create a new folder name called
components
and inside this components
we will create some file name called
login
dot
js
likewise we would like to create a
register
user
details.js
one more
name call
portfolio
so we have got these pages already with
me
okay
out of which i want the first components
to be get launched here that is known as
call a landing page so here i will also
create
landing
so let's go back and create a new
components here which will be helping us
to
move
here and there
so first thing in my landing page my
component.js i have a call app.js which
is a base component for me
so as i can see this is how you go back
and create a new
functional component so i just copy the
same
and here in login.json paste it
and give the name to
login
login and here we can say welcome to
login i just
this is my small component i copied
and i pasted in the portfolio
so you can portfolio welcome to
folio register
register
okay you know called user
details okay so we have got these
components with us
i will start with
landing page first
so
i would like to create a class based
component here
so
import
react
from
react now
4d for class
landing page
exchange
component
now
render
return
okay so this is
the one so we called tube tag here
well
this is my component which is available
to me
so the landing page is a component which
through which i'll start working on
so i can say
welcome to landing so here i want this
components to be available outside
so what i will do is
this landing page in my index.js
i'll make it as the first component to
be launched
landing page
so when i start my application i should
see here
okay welcome to lending is coming up
perfect
so this has become my first component
which i
want to launch and furthermore we would
like to add few more components here
okay so in a previous program we have
seen
how to create a multiple components and
how we can make one of the component as
a learning component now it's our next
program where we will be enabling the
routing into our code
syllable
landing page we would like to create
some more
dependency we are saying import
from
react hyphen router hyphen down so we'll
be choosing those dependencies one by
one but from there
we want to start working
with cons routes
equal to
first thing
as we discussed with you that is we
would like to start with the browser
router
okay
so
from this point onwards we would like to
start with
switch
as you can see they are taking from the
react router down
after the switch we will say
route
okay so here
with this route we would like to see the
navigation path we say path
equal to if it is
login
then which component i want to launch so
we can say
component
here i'll say c small
component equal to
okay
it's not loading so we can say import
and since i want to launch
the component which is a type of login
so we can say import
from login
so if you see here
we work on login so we will be using
this login only
okay
so this is my login component likewise i
will say
from
register so here
we would like to say
login
and
in a similar way
we also want to have the another
registration
we copy the same
use this
register
register
so this is how the components are used
here
okay
well
these are the quick two components we
have created one is called login in the
second core register
after that what you will be doing this
routes you will be adding it under this
div tag so i'm removing this landing
page
and here
i will give the name call
routes that's it
so once this route has been given
now it's time for us to
see
what it differs
so landing page
or sorry we have a register we have a
register also
so
[Music]
say route is not defined so what we can
do
we can also import that out from this
page now let's go back
okay nothing is shown so now we have to
manually type by saying
login you can see i've got this message
go welcome to login
now let's see register
and there we go register so two
components are loaded correctly now we
would like to import two more
import
[Music]
portfolio
portfolio
okay
and last
we have a call a user details
import name call
user details here
so we got user details let me copy these
two
so register
portfolio
so this is how
our components are so now
we can see all registered successfully
well in our previous program we have
seen we were typing those urls manually
into our browser
but in real time this won't be a
solution
in a real time you would like to make
this example
by clicking on a hyperlink you would
like to make it possible
so i will be doing this
so to make it possible what you will be
doing is
like here itself you create a new
component called
header
okay
so this is how we're going to create the
new component called header
so within this
you're going to add
the new
i call header within this you will be
using
nav link which is once again
the tool provided by
react to which you can create a
hyperlinks
so this is the nav link for you
so within this nav link you will provide
the option like in 2
equal to
login
and
along with this
you will also provide
the name so here i say
login let me copy the same
login
register
register
we also have called
last we have called
portfolio
so this is my component which is
available to me and this i would like to
use
within my application so here
after this browser router
we would like to add the component call
header here
that's it that's the only thing we need
to do now this header component is now
the part of
routes and let's see how it makes a
difference now you can see
very clearly it is having those links
with me and now when i click on those
links
you can see how these are easily
accessible to all of us
okay so these are the links which are
available to us through which we can
make our components
simple and easy to access
one more thing we can do it here
and what's that
this component whichever we are talking
about okay
this component we can attach
to one of my
component when my components start it
should work automatically so i can do
one thing let my login command to be the
base component for me
so in order to make this possible i need
to write one more tool here called
exact equal to
true
and here also we have to use the same
so here
we would like to add one more property
here
okay and we will say exact equal to true
okay what i would like to use
exact equal to true
that's it any job is done now let's
check
and now you can see the by default login
page appeared
because the login is in root location
and that's all
your url works
okay everybody so in a previous examples
we have seen how the links are working
but these links are all internal links
but what in case if i want to go to the
external link so let's try to understand
that point
so here let me try to open up
i'm opening up simply learn link and i'm
clicking on this
the url is right now https
simplylearn.com
that's a link which is available so let
me try to copy this link
and uh
here
if you want to go to that location so
what do we need to do now
so to make it possible
here i can just make this another nav
link
copy the same
then i give the name called
simpler
and
and here i'll just copy the same
okay
so now it's asking me for the component
because i do not have any component here
right now
so here what i will be doing instead
i am making it as a blank
okay and here
i want to give window
dot location
dot
href
equal to
the website which is available
okay so that will be the link which i'm
providing it now
and
after this link what has been provided
i'm saying
return
that's it
okay so that will be the link
so i'm saving this and going back to
this
location now
so you can see we have a call simply
that the moment i click it here
so
it will somehow try to take me towards
where
this external website the one which we
are actually looking forward for
okay so this is the way
through which you can basically make
the application accessible outside so if
i just go back to my browser and uh
[Music]
refresh this and click on signature and
you can see now it took me to an
external location called simplyland.com
likewise if i just go back and open
the
simple learn
as a youtube channel
also just say
okay simply learn
youtube so if any of the
i would say
the link
which is available right you can see
right now we have a card
multiple website so if i just click or
anything suppose
this is a link for me
and
i try to create one more link here
just like we have a call simply learn so
let's create one more let's say
simply learn youtube
simply on youtube so here
i copy the same
okay so here
in my browser whatever the link is
provided let's just copy this link
and
paste this link right over there
okay so this is what a link which is
available to me
now i go back to my code
i can say simply run youtube i click it
and you can see it took me two way to
the other
so this is the way you see
how the links are basically created
and they are simply available to us
in a very simplified manner
okay and that's where
the hyperlinks are basically working
with us
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here